Every movie fans has their favorite superhero,
supervillain, or offbeat comic book star that
they would love to see done justice on the
big screen.
But as cruel as it might be to be kept waiting
years to see it, it hurts just as much when
a beloved character's debut is a disappointement.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Comic Book Characters
Who Deserve Better Movies.
Kitty Pryde
Thanks to the X-Men series of movies, people
might think that Kitty Pryde - played by Ellen
Page - is a permanent sidekick, but the mutant
ability to phase through objects or people
is just the start of what makes her unique.
She developed into one of the most experienced
X-Men since her introduction, even being chosen
by writer Joss Whedon as the star of his "Astonishing
X-Men."
Who wouldn't want a movie about a girl who
can kick, grab or tackle people through walls,
or if pushed, phase a moon-sized bullet right
through planet Earth?
That's what we thought.
The Incredible Hulk
It's sad to think that fans are still begging
for a homerun Hulk movie after the green-skinned
hero has already had two solo films.
Hopefully Marvel starts to realize that Bruce
Banner a.k.a. the Hulk's mythology is as complicated
as any comic hero, having split his personality,
travelled to faraway planets, and even waged
war on all of Earth's superheroes.
How his films keep being dragged down by a
cookie-cutter romance is beyond us.
Gambit
The Ragin' Cajun got his big screen debut
as a back-up player in X-Men Origins: Wolverine,
but the mutant had almost nothing in common
with his fan-favorite comic book and cartoon
source material.
Blessed with a knack for theft and the ability
to give objects immeasurable kinetic energy,
a solo movie following Gambit a.k.a. Remy
Lebeau's Louisiana hijinks should be as slick
a superhero movie as they come.
Hopefully, the Channing Tatum movie in development
will even come close to matching the hero's
coolness.
Cyclops
Thanks to the X-Men movies, the world knows
Cyclops best as the joyless, rule-loving rival
to the ultra-cool Wolverine - who can shoot
lasers out of his eyes.
That's a tragic definition of one of the most
powerful, most courageous, and most dependable
mutants in Marvel history.
Even without his powers, Scott Summers is
a born leader, willing to do, or become whatever
is necessary to get the job done.
He SHOULD be on the same level as Captain
America in the movies, and make one point
clear: as long as Cyclops is alive to fight,
mutantkind will never be beaten.
Catwoman
In an age of superheroes who are either squeaky-clean
or beyond saving, you would think that a character
like Catwoman would thrive.
Sure, she's a thief and master criminal in
general, but she knows where to draw the line,
helping Batman when he's in need - as in,
save him or he'll die.
The solo movie Catwoman got was an absolute
disaster, with most of the problems due to
the fact that the movie character had almost
nothing in common with the source material.
But give us a Catwoman as compelling and confident
as the comics, and Ben Affleck's Batman will
have met his match.
Green Lantern
No fan of DC Comics needs to be told that
the Green Lantern movie fell short of its
hero's mythology, and can only hope that Warner
Bros. makes sure they get the Justice League
hero right the second time around.
And the hero SHOULD be a hit, since his superpower
is quite literally whatever he can imagine,
made real by his magical ring.
As every other blockbuster tries to find a
new way to destroy Earth, there's no better
time for a Green Lantern movie to head to
an even bigger scale, uniting an army of Lantern
space cops to protect the universe, not just
one planet.
Venom
Ask any fan of Spider-Man who the webslinger's
greatest enemy is, and they might disagree.
But ask them which is the coolest - and it's
Venom every time.
The version of the alien/human hybrid that
movie fans got in Spider-Man 3 was a disappointment
from the start, more quippy villain than horrifying
monster.
We can only hope that a writer, director or
studio will finally realize that a black-suited
beast with Spider-Man's powers - and none
of his do-gooder attitude - isn't just a villain,
but a potential franchise all on his own.
John Constantine
He may not get the headlines or press of his
superpowered Justice League comrades, but
when the League can't handle a magical threat,
it's John Constantine they call.
He operates on a level that DC's brightest
stars can't even touch, inhabiting a shadowy
world of demons and angels that most never
even notice.
The Constantine movie actually got much of
the attitude and fiction right, but if a movie
committed to creating a hero as ruthless,
nasty, and downright unlikeable as the real
John Constantine, the result would be something
refreshing, if nothing else.
Heck, we'll even settle for Justice League
Dark.
Black Widow
Sure, Scarlett Johansson has helped make Black
Widow a household name alongside the Avengers,
but without a superpower, she's a long way
from a starring role in a Marvel movie so
far.
Fans loved The Winter Soldier's grounded style,
so imagine what they'd do with a dark, sinister
spy story following Black Widow doing what
she does best: operating in the shadows as
S.H.I.E.L.D.'s top covert operative.
So far fans have only heard about the death-defying
missions she's survived with Hawkeye at her
side - so what's keeping Marvel from giving
us an entire movie devoted to the same badass
leading lady?
Robin
He may be forever known as Batman's sidekick,
but comic fans know that Robin, no matter
which version, is deserving of a spotlight
all to himself.
Whether it's Dick Grayson promoted to Nightwing,
one of the most badass characters of DC's
1990s era, or Tim Drake, the only Robin to
apply for the job, and an even better detective
than Batman - not to mention the leader of
the Teen Titans.
Even if a big screen story gave the spotlight
to Jason Todd, the former robin who became
the murderous vigilante Red Hood, DC fans
would know that a one-of-a-kind story and
star was guaranteed).
Those are just a handful of comic book heroes
or villains that deserve better live-action
adaptations than they've gotten so far, but
which comic book stars do you think have been
given a bad rap by Hollywood blockbusters?
Educate us in the comments, and remember to
subscribe for more videos like this one!